[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down some brand new leaks and
rumors on Doctor Strange 3. it's a film
that's actually going to be very
important once we get into the upcoming
phases and this movie's gonna have major
repercussions on Avengers Kang Dynasty
Cosmic circus has just dropped a big
report going over what's happening in it
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking it all down normally I don't
talk about leaks with a film this far
from release but it actually lines up
with a lot of stuff I've heard it's been
pitched for the movie and I'll of course
be talking about that in the video as
well obviously heavy spoilers ahead
potentially Sophia if you don't want to
know anything then please switch off now
this is your first time here then also
hit that thumbs up button and make sure
you subscribe for videos like this every
day but out of the way huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into
these Doctor Strange three leaks the
illumawati like I said before this comes
from Alex Perez who's gotten a number of
things right at Cosmic circus when it
comes to the MCU Perez has said that
before the strikes took place so there
were a lot of Concepts floating around
for the next film and it'll apparently
pick up immediately after the events of
Multiverse of Madness now in it will be
following strange and clear as the
former get his help with fixing the
incursions Perez has stated the movie is
going to Loosely adapt the graphic novel
time runs out which in case you haven't
read it don't worry we've got you
covered I'm nice like that now that
takes place during Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers run and it happens just before
everything majorly kicks off in the main
event's Secret Wars in the build-up tour
you had Hickman writing two bucks side
by side that tell the story of what was
going on with the incursions and how the
Illuminati were handling them in New
Avengers we watched as the Illuminati
worked in secret to stop the 616 being
destroyed by the incursions whereas in
The Avengers book The Heroes went about
their business just saving the world
completely unaware of what was going on
in the shadows now what happened in
Avengers vs X-Men is that Captain
America learned about the Illuminati and
there's Tony Stark trying to show that
he changed his ways he invited him to
become a member he let him be part of
the decision making at least for like a
couple of months but when things got to
the incursions they realized he wasn't
the guy for the job now I was kicked out
was all down to the incursing Earths
because cap refused to make the tough
choices in regards to them and trying to
stop the first one they ended up using
The Infinity Gauntlet and this was so
they could push the other Earth back and
save everyone one on both Earths however
doing this actually shattered all the
stones except for the time one and the
Illuminati realized that in order to
stop the incursions that they'd have to
get their hands dirty they were gonna
have to make the tough decision and
destroy the other Earths but cap refused
to do this which caused a lot of issues
now the Illuminati realized that they
had no other choice and in the end there
is Captain America's memory Tony Stark
created something known as Avengers
world and this was just going to keep
him occupied whilst they worked away in
secret now this involved cap recruiting
Heroes across the planet and it was just
basically busy work that kept his
attention elsewhere that was during the
story original sin that his memories
came back and he realized exactly what
the Illuminati were up to in that the
Watcher was murdered and one of his eyes
was stolen which was used as a way to
unleash all that he had seen since he
watched everything going on with the
Illuminati Steve got his memory back and
then declared the Illuminati an enemy of
the world so they all went into hiding
and time Runs Out picks up eight months
after they've been declared out Outlaws
there's a lot going on with it but
basically it's about the incursions
getting to the point where most of the
Multiverse is destroyed and there's just
a couple of universes left that are all
on a collision course be here all day if
we go through all the internets of that
but I have to talk about that at least
to add some context to what comes next
now Perez said that in the film strange
will be teaming up with a multiversal
organization called the black priests
which clear is apparently a member of in
the comics she didn't have anything to
do with them but Juni 8-month time Jump
strange ended up becoming their leader
now in the build up the time runs out
they were seen as extremely powerful
beings and sometimes they'd show up
during an incursion to destroy the
incursing Earths completely ruthless
they were near impossible to defeat and
they were one of the greatest Mysteries
surrounding the entire story it turned
out that each of their members had a
word that they knew and when combined
together each one of these formed a
spell for example say one of them uses
the word like and the other uses the
word hit but you then have the other two
that have the word the and button they
can make the spell hit the like button
but in there also lies their weakness if
one of the priests was killed they'd be
unable to ever use that word again
unless the Spells would have to change
and they'd have to come up with some new
ones now an expedition was sent out
during the eight months to look for the
priests and it's at this point that they
came across their leader in strange
strange actually sold his entire soul
during the build up to time runs out
because he wanted absolute power and in
order to gain this you had to sell your
entire soul but he did it and Lucy
became an extremely powerful wizard now
according to the leaks they're sort of
adapting The Bare Bones of that and
strange you'll end up working with the
priest to stop the incursions from
happening he'll be seen as someone who's
the common denominator when it comes to
what's causing the incursions and this
is something that was actually touched
upon in Multiverse of Madness from our
experience the greatest danger to the
Multiverse it turns out
is Doctor Strange now it'll be revealed
in the end the incursions are also being
caused by the Council of kangs and this
will all build up to the next Avengers
film as for what I heard they're going
to be leaning heavily into also bringing
across the general theme of molecule man
and this will be seen in either wander
or Doctor Strange in case you don't know
basically the molecule man someone who
in the comics was a multiversal bomb
across all realities created by the
beyonders they made Owen Reese someone
who was the same across all universes
and they granted him with Incredible
abilities their plan was to detonate all
the visions of Owen reset once and this
would then destroy everything in the
Multiverse in one go Dr Doom actually
learned of this plan and whilst all the
stuff with the Illuminati was going on
he had another plot happening in the
background of the book it turned out
Doom had been going from reality to
reality murdering every version of Owen
Reese in order to stop them from having
a way to destroy that reality however
with the Multiverse being vast and
infinite he had to come up with a way to
do it quicker and thus he ended up
creating his own religion in
indoctrinating young women known as the
black swans they traveled throughout the
Multiverse forum and killed every
version of Reese they came across now
that person being a multiversal constant
is something that I can see happening
with either Wanda or Steven both peered
into other realities and they also use
the dark holder dream walk into them and
this was one of the causes of the
incursions whereas in the MCU they
operate slightly differently staying on
another world for too long can bring it
into collision with another and thus I
think the initial cause of the
incursions will be put down to Doctor
Strange the way you have to look at it
is it's like they're sort of marbles on
the ground and if one is hit it has a
knock on effect that smacks into the
others this leads to everything just
having a big domino effect and in the
end every world ends up destroyed now in
the comics killing that first oh and
Reese that was what caused the first
incursion and this ended up having a big
knock on effect as the worlds collided
into each other it actually took over 20
years to get to the point where it Came
Crashing Down In Time runs out and we
may actually get some recording in the
MCU where they explain more what
happened to cause them to be incursions
in the first place I've heard from
various people that the mcu's molecule
man is either Wonder or strange and that
at the root of everything is them
causing the occasions to happen it makes
sense too going off what we learned in
Multiverse of Madness and that common
from the Illuminati seems to highlight
what's happening strange exists in every
reality and from what we've seen in that
and what if he's the same there too this
is also the case with Wonder as she's
considered an axis being two and there's
way more prophecies tied to her as well
so that that might make more sense
either way I'd love to hear your
thoughts on it lots of information
dumped there but yeah hopefully we've
kind of clarified exactly what we think
is going to be happening obviously we're
still very early days but I thought this
stuff was worth talking about because
look if you've read Secret Wars you'll
know how good it is and any excuse to
talk about it I'm gonna talk about it
okay so yeah that wraps it up and please
drop a like on the video I think that's
a third time I've I've begged you for it
um and if you want to support the
channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping us out the channel you've
almost hit 150 members which I can't
believe you guys are going to support us
that much it really means a lot and yeah
hopefully uh you click that button and
you know get get some Early Access to
videos if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
Brighton of across the spider verse from
your boy Mt that goes over every single
thing in the movie and all the
references in it he's done an amazing
job with it as well and yeah hopefully I
see you over there right after this
about the way huge thank you for
thinking through the video I'll be
important and I'll see you next time
take care peace